[موسيقى]
للاقتراب اكثر من حياه الصابئه المدنيه
وكيف تعيش العائله المندائيه في ظل هذه
التشاريع زرنا منزل السيد مصطفى عبود احد
اعضاء العائله الخميسيه المندئيه التي
كانت تشكل الاغلبيه من بين عوائل
المندائيين هي الطائفيه اجت مثل ما يقول
بغرائسه الخبيثه وحتى المطر
فاحنا نصيبنا مثل بيقول مثل ما انه
الاديان الباقيه اجاها افطر هذا
الاسلام سنه وشيعه او الشبك او الفويلين
اول لما اجوا على كل
شرائح المجتمع العراق العراقي
عليهم
يقول لا حول ولا قوه
[موسيقى]
بطبيعه الطائفه اللي هي طائفه دينيه فلدين
يربط يربط الابناء الصعبه المندائيين اكثر
اكثر فاكثر تجدنا نعرف
ويكاد احد يعرف انساب الاخر احد متقارب مع
الاخر يا اما بالاخوه اولى اما بالعمومه
تربطنا
وشائج فيما بيننا الرابط الاساسي هو الدين
همم طقوس تجمعنا المراسيم تجمعنا